bienvenidos a la ciencia de las ciencias
como la pizza oriana porque tal vez está
lista en tanda o también se te hace la
creencias más espantosa de la historia
la utilización del jamón y la pontaise
hay quien dice que la mejor forma de
personas practicantes contar mi historia
yo empecé con un chiste pero alemán
historia mi hermana estudió diseño
industrial nuestro y física y siempre su
mente es súper interesante todo lo que
hace mi hermana hay quien dice que
muchísima ciencia en el arte y contigo
veía que llegaba y me diría es cortada
diseñada desde es verdad hay muchísima
ciencia en el arte y siempre nada como
ir en ser vida porque entonces a
experiencia de que por hoy mete una
manzana más hoy hicimos algo para curar
a amazonas y yo pues la situación
nuestra está padre y simplemente mi
hermana era máximo el problema es que
tenemos una de las cinco las matemáticas
superman y como que no entendemos para
qué son y aparecerá distintos a la
historia no porque está en primaria
listas con fracciones divertidas
y símbolos y los odias para siempre
estas marcas está tu vida y te acaso las
que ya sabes en además sumas en la
cuenta del 2.15 va así y ya la psoriasis
es porque la carrera no tiene matemática
esta clase es fácil
y el problema con las matemáticas
estivales por siempre la pregunta para
qué sirve para qué sirve hacer cálculos
para qué sirve hacer todo esto y todo
durante el significado de una razón
estamos a significado detrás de las
cosas también completamente la forma en
la que lo hacemos simplemente físico
[Música]
pero no lo que dije es que de hecho no
me agrade y genera física de hecho me
cuenta que no quería hacer eso también
sentimos en estrés
[Música]
y de hecho me di cuenta que lo que me
apasionaba las historias y la
creatividad y soy lector de una agencia
creativa estamos que estamos cambiando
en puntos negros increíbles y como decía
el otro mover las historia de las
conexiones y lo más increíble fue
descubrir que esta creatividad también
están precisamente en las ciencias y el
problema con las matemáticas es que
todos hemos olvidado una una cosa que
puede cambiarlo todo y esto es que las
matemáticas no son nada más nada más y
nada menos que un lenguaje único que
salga del universo que nos habla de cómo
se mueve todo de nosotros así como el
español dice meza o dice member gatito o
te pregunta cuál es tu ubicación así
también las matemáticas de movimiento y
sin reacción o dicen tiro parabólico por
ejemplo
el problema es como solidario
completamente entonces de los
matemáticas son como jeroglíficos y no
entendemos nada y un montón de símbolos
extraños que nunca vas a usar en tu vida
es por eso que es un ejercicio sencillo
matemáticas
tenemos que entender
que es que dice una ecuación porque los
factores nos dicen cosas cuando
entendemos que las ecuaciones no son
cálculos en una hoja no son jeroglíficos
en chino no son tareas exámenes y
reprobar todas las materias de tu vida
que los ángulos de las ecuaciones nos
dicen cosas del mundo que todo cambia
entonces para este ejercicio
vamos a usar esto esta es la lírica no
suena horrible
efe si ballack a uno por nudos entre
cuadradas un examen es una tarea zona
que a traste y que cuando entendemos que
la ley coloque ley común dice no es
difícil sino lo que él ha echo lo hice
es escribe cómo interactúan dos cargas
eléctricas en el espacio y seremos esto
cambia no hicimos el visualizador suena
como aunque horrible pero si entendemos
el concepto detrás cambia mucho la mente
la cruz entonces hacer una ecuación lo
que dice la ley colom es que la fuerza
entre dos cargas en el espacio aumentan
cuando la carga
cargas currículos son más grandes y
disminuyen con los que es la visión le
ponemos modelo bien rápido si la cabeza
constante para liberarlo la carga burgos
la cara dos estrés y la distancia entre
a 64 cuando la fuerza 3.3 listo con
fácil ciencia ahora qué pasa si la
distancia entre las cargas sea menor o
sea más de cuatro parados que espero que
pase con la fuerza
y por esto estoy cuando estás en tu casa
en un domingo vacío y a grados sin antes
porque son los hilos acerca serpiente
pongo pegando y los los atletas visto
grandes y escuchas gratos y de repente
los zetas y tú se pegan de nuevo porque
la puerta de atracción entre estos dos
imanes se hace mayor cuando la distancia
de ellos suele menor así simple mis
hermanos indiferente a las matemáticas
cuando hace tenemos como decía vemos
cero glíficos
esto es mecánica la anciana
estación mecánico para nuestros
complejos esto es un poco
esto es ecuaciones de ley de kepler
también espantoso horrible pero es
porque entendemos lo que está azúcar nos
dice si vemos cálculos y vemos números
espantosos suena horrible pero porque lo
hicimos proporción de las mentes
pequeñas que no tendremos muchos vemos
jeroglíficos las mentes más increíbles
de universos jóvenes
las casas de la granja utilizan para
diseñar la estrategia y salida de los
cohetes para llegar al espacio para
minimizar el uso de combustible y
contrastar gravedad
el principio de tránsito no describe la
forma en la que los árboles crecen para
colocar sus raíces italia para contratar
la póliza de gravedad
laszlo y las hojas se cortan de acuerdo
al principio de también toma
y por último las leyes de la galaxia y
ahora se necesitan una forma diferente
de ver la vida nuestra forma
completamente diferente de la ciencia y
las matemáticas sentimos más estoy
confundido con las estrellas en grande y
sí sí entiendo pues al menos entiendo lo
que pasa y lo harás también estás pero
sabes y es la forma más útil de las
matemáticas se nos olvida de que nadie
quizá nos enseñó
y los más increíbles de matemáticas y
con esto llegó a la parte más importa
esta práctica sin activar una cosa al
ibex ésta es que lo más increíble no es
lo cálculo es simple que existan
porque ahora es que las adecuaciones y
con eso de escribir y predecir cómo va
terna pelota por como tercer pasto o
cómo se mueven los astros porque quien
inventó esto porque puesto que ésta esté
pero nosotros y la respuesta
sencillísima pero completísima a la vez
es que el universo hay orden
y en diversas reglas lines time tiene
una frase que lo escribe increíble es
que lo más incomprensible del universo
es que es comprensible que el universo
podría ser y no es de la super bien
definidas que no se rompe nunca y que
dicen que los átomos detractores entre
sí y que forman elementos y compuestos
conforman tejidos por no me informan que
está completamente y esto y para
entender un poquito error del universo
que es inexplicable que veamos un par de
sitios muy sencillos vamos tenemos que
ser ahora serie numérica bien sencillo
pero su número uno y lo que vamos a
hacer es sumar la cta número uno
anterior porque 2012
13 38 y 21 y si son científicos
pero
la serie es el elemento italiano en los
1900 su nombre es leonardo de pisa
iglesia antigua china para escuchar el
nombre y le puso a esto él estaba
estudiando compensadas presente con
ellos y le puso esto la serie de
fibonacci porque pues a la gente la
gente le pone sus nombres a las cosas y
mentadas vamos al otro ejercicio bajo en
construir cuadrados con cada uno de los
números de la serie 5 h 2 cuadrados de
uno por uno de 2 por 2 metros por 3 de 5
por 5 de 8 por 8 13 21 34
estamos con esto y ahora vamos a unir
los puntos de las esquinas de estos
cuadrados están las esquinas y las
seguimos con la línea
y acabamos con esto que se llama la
espiral de ser bueno para que se les dé
una después para que sirva si con el
tiempo descubrimos que increíblemente
resulta que está en todos lados
la de tele tribunal por ejemplo describe
la forma la que crecen los caparazones
de los moluscos la forma de crecer los
nopales la forma en los tallos la forma
de la galaxia la forma de los huracanes
la forma la que se habla tu mano cuando
lo hiciera es tu puño en la forma de
oreja la forma de tu nariz alrededor de
cara la forma en la que crecen
obviamente reportante con ecos y
precisión todo y describir todo y si las
espectaculares tividad como un concepto
tan sencillo tal un jueguito que sacamos
aquí en 30 segundos puede estar en dos
partes cinturón universo y no solamente
en la física para eso quiero mostrarles
otra cosa hay una pintura en el museo en
francia que se ha visto es un cuadro muy
chiquito pero la gente es un montón de
fila para verlo
y es este
qué pasaría si vemos con detenimiento la
pintura
lo que pasaría probablemente es que lo
muerden por qué
y la parálisis una pintura que toda la
historia la hemos alargado porque vemos
que tiene una geometría muy bonita es
muy fácil de ver ya que no adivinan qué
estructura que me describe la forma la
analizan
precisamente la historia de fibonacci
escribe la relación de la pintura y la
forma en la que sus manos están
colocadas alrededor resultadas del
mentón su barbilla y si nace
espectacular estirada piense el
bronceado elección que algo tan simple
que escupieron en 1200 está en todas las
áreas del universo y que la creación
humana es espectacular el hecho que
todos estamos hechos de tan pocas cosas
con tan pocas tan pocos conceptos que
está en todos lados
bueno y ésta está como este hecho que
todos estamos hechos de lo mismo es lo
más increíble también y de hecho la
mente de todos en la física también las
estrellas por ejemplo son como enormes
reactores nucleares con hornos dentro de
los cuales se forman los elementos que
forman todo el mante del universo y una
estrella explotar y expulsar a miles y
millones de átomos a millones de
kilómetros por hora por todo el universo
que viajan por las estrellas actualmente
llegan a la tierra luego forman parte de
las plantas y eventualmente forman parte
de ti
pincel visita esto significa que cada
átomo cada átomo de tu cuerpo y todos
los que quieres y además conoce de
nuestra actividad viene literalmente del
centro de las estrellas y serás
espectacular estatales por eso cuando
nos tiramos al casco y vemos las
estrellas nos da tanto algo grande que
nos ya porque tales nos llama a ese
lugar determinemos todos
y nos llama el somos parte de este
universo espectacular que vemos y que
nos maravilla y tú eres literalmente
parte de eso hay una nota que me gusta
mucho
el pensar que una estrella murió para
que estés aquí en la historia donde
todos han visto la película estaba word
si no lo han visto es el momento para
whatsapp porque pues por la empresa
mismo pero la tecla sabes por la carrera
de grande cooper muere justo en el
instante que la carrera eliminada
despega
porque para que una estrella nazca otro
extremo
y nuestra parte se hizo más espectacular
y somos parte de esta grandeza y sin
hacer está más increíble este
descubrimiento hay un científico nuevo
sistema con sagan que tiene una frase
que lo escribe espectacularmente y es
esta somos polvo de estrellas que piensa
en polvo de estrellas
víctor es parte de esa dinámica de hecho
es el centro de dinámica más increíble
de pensar que tal vez un átomo que nació
junto a un gato tuyo sea un átomo
hermano en auto motivo está lesión forma
parte de un planeta en la constelación
lejana quizás que vemos de las noches de
verano ante el camino
[Música]
y tal vez un órgano del átomo tuyo forma
parte de la luna que va a haber caminar
tus hijos que pueden llegar a la tierra
como ver caminar a tus abuelitos que ya
no están
o tal vez un átomo hermano un ratón
forma parte de los ojos de la persona
que más amas en el mundo
esa persona en la que pienso no puedes
pensar nada más
dicen a ser más espectacular el hecho de
que todos somos parte de esto que está
este universo gigante y porque esto eres
tú vienes de su corazón hecho de flamas
con nuevos hechos del universo con toda
la infinidad de desfase en contra de
proto corazón con la posibilidad de
cambiar cada cosa que vives y cada cosa
que eres y clases por cuenta de la forma
en que vives y la norma la que estudian
la forma que las montañas y los mares y
lagos del cielo y otros amigos ya la
sigue la que está sentada al pensar que
todos somos parte está en la unidad
indescriptible que lutero existir
sanación o más espectacular pensar en
esto y cuando descubrí esto descubrí que
tenemos este universo enorme enfrente de
nosotros gritando unos que nada este
tiene sentido y de los que somos parte
de esta utilidad y que nada es la
explicación y este orden indescriptible
pero dentro existe pero existe y que la
física y las matemáticas y que ya
galaxia y la pizza piña o ante ti tú
esto en ese momento encontrar respuesta
para preguntarme
y para contestar la pregunta de mi
hermana para esto para esto sirven las
islas matemáticas para entender para
apreciar
[Música]
es
la tierra
[Música]
además siente muchísimo en la ciencia
ayudarte le reduce preguntas porque si
el universo una canción y entonces las
matemáticas son la letra
y siente las matemáticas son lenguajes
como el español
y entonces se convierte en el más grande
y hermoso bueno
y si quieres conocer al más grande poeta
de todos los tiempos lo único que tienes
que hacer es detenerte voltear y school
está en un libro de poesía
[Aplausos]